eu tenho raiva e com freqüência esse
sentimento bate na minha
porta outro dia eu achei bastante graça
quando uma amiga minha me disse assim
nati mas você instrutora demais né como
você pode ter raiva e aí eu falei pra
ela me olha o sentimento eu tenho
o exercício é como eu ajo em cima dele
e afinal de contas eu sou instrutora
demais né seu prático mais né
mas eu não sou duda e vão combinar que o
próprio guga disse que cada um de nós
tem a semente de todos os sentimentos
a diferença é qual a gente escolhe regar
e foi lá em meados de 2012
quando eu percebi que eu não estava
regando as sementes das árvores que
trariam os frutos mais saborosos pra mim
eu quase entrei em depressão e aí eu
decidi que aquele não era o caminho pra
mim e que o meu caminho era buscar ser
uma pessoa melhor e aí nesse meio do
caminho e descobriu mais feliz que eu
não vou contar agora pra vocês o que é
eu vou contá já porque antes disso eu
preciso falar de cérebro e eu preciso
falar de evolução
a gente aqui é com essas roupas que a
gente usa com tudo isso a gente não é
muito diferente do homem pré histórico
mas o que diferencia a gente de outros
seres humanos que foram dizimados aí na
nossa história é a nossa ao nosso
cérebro
a gente era muito indefeso pequenininho
uma infância muito longa mas foi essa
infância longa que fez com que o nosso
cérebro desenvolver-se algumas partes
que fez com que a gente conseguisse usar
mais a razão e também se relacionar
melhor entre as pessoas
vamos voltar um pouquinho no passado la
na história 300 mil anos talvez ea gente
vamos supor que a gente está saindo da
nossa caverna saindo da nossa caverna
com o tacape na mão e aí de repente a
gente se depara com leon
segundo nosso cérebro a gente tem três
possibilidades ou a gente luta ou a
gente foge ou a gente finge de morto não
tem chance nenhuma de dialogar com esse
leão
bom então voltamos para os dias atuais
a gente está saindo das nossas casas e
tem uma reunião difícil o nosso chefe é
uma situação tão ameaçadora quanto esse
leão aqui a gente tem três opções ou
luta ocorre ou fingir de morto
eu acho que já estou imaginando algumas
situações não mas na verdade se a gente
treinar o nosso cérebro a gente consegue
fazer com que ele encontra alternativas
isso não é fácil exige um exercício mas
é aí que o mais um exemplo e mais
urgente não é nada mais nada menos do
que escolher prestar atenção é em alguma
coisa sem julgar essa coisa de escolher
prestar atenção nessa coisa
a ciência já comprovou um monte de
efeito relacionada à saúde física à
saúde mental emocional melhora nos
relacionamentos eu mesma comprovei na
prática e é sobre isso que eu quero
falar com cada um de vocês aqui como que
isso tem mudado a minha vida e como que
pode mudar a vida de vocês é uma nova
forma de olhar e uma nova forma de olhar
o nosso próximo sem escolher quem é o
meu próximo
bom então uma a primeira a primeira
etapa é a gente olhar pra dentro da
gente e o autoconhecimento ele pode
surgir de várias formas você pode no
psicólogo
você pode fazer terapias alternativas
pode fazer-se uma pastoral também os há
testes do facebook tudo isso vai trazer
alguma informação sobre a gente ea gente
é tão interessante que vocês vão
perceber que esse caminho não termina
sempre tem mais alguma coisa própria
descobrir sobre si próprio e nesse
caminho vocês vão se deparar com sombras
com certeza porque afinal a gente só é a
gente só vê as estrelas por causa da
escuridão e neste momento quando a gente
se deparar com uma sombra nossa a gente
tem que ser generoso com a gente
entender que a gente é humano que a
gente vai errar e que tem né um um leque
a id de comportamentos que a gente vai
que a gente vai operar então é por isso
que é importante a gente ser generoso
primeiro com a gente mesmo
então uma sugestão que eu dou pra vocês
todo dia a gente lá no banho que por que
não aproveitar o banho pra fazer um
carinho na gente para massagear a gente
e tudo bem então seja generoso com você
depois disso vocês vão perceber os
padrões negativos é importante mudar não
é só ser compreensivo é importante mudar
aquilo que não está legal e pra isso uma
sugestão que eu posso dar pra vocês é
sair do piloto automático é fazer coisas
que vocês não estão acostumados a fazer
então é por exemplo é escovar o dente
com a mão não dominante ela vá louça
prestando atenção na louça é ficar com o
celular desligado mora que dão uma
sociedade que cobra a gente está
conectado o tempo inteiro então
experimente essas coisas novas e isso
vai fazer com que vocês
por incrível que pareça sejam mais
criativos e para ajudar nessa
criatividade é importante também que
vocês aprendam coisas novas
várias coisas podem fazer curso vai me
ver no texas pode fazer um monte de
coisa eu no meu último contato com o
professor de maio fazendo levou a gente
pra surfar é fui para algo que eu
esperava fazer a minha vida inteira mas
eu sempre pedia desculpas até muito frio
ainda muito calor
aí eu não sei nadar o mar agitado marca
muito calmo vai lá na frente que jogou
jajá e eu fui buscando desculpas até a
hora que eu cheguei falei assim eu sou a
próxima
e aí já não tinha mais tempo pra dar
desculpas e eu entrei falaram que quando
eu sair do mar
eu estava com um sorriso de orelha a
orelha foi um sonho realizado e valeu
muito a pena eu percebi que eu mesma em
que tentava medos para não realizar
alguns sonhos meus então se vocês são a
pedra no caminho de aprender alguma
coisa nova
pegue essa pedra joga longe só você tem
o poder de fazer isso e também vale
olhar para o novo grupo antigo com
outros olhos também aprender bom nessa e
nesse exercício também vocês vão
perceber que é importante fazer coisas
só por vocês próprios muito me assusta
quando eu escuto uma pessoa dizer assim
ah eu não tenho robin e aí eu penso
assim bom das duas uma ou a pessoa não
sabe nem o que ela faz durante o dia ou
ela tem uma vida miserável e e eu acho
lindo uma pessoa que dedica sua vida
seus filhos eu acho lindo quem tem um
trabalho que dá prazer
mas o que eu tô falando aqui é fazer
algo só por você que só você pode fazer
então por exemplo se você gosta de ler
livros e não consegue encaixar isso na
sua rotina que tal um parágrafo ou se
você quer fazer um exercício físico e
também não consegue encaixar isso no seu
dia a dia que tal fazer um pólo chinelo
um par de chinelo é no nível do ridículo
algo que você pode não pode dizer assim
não não vou fazer
é nesse nível que eu gostaria que você
chegasse é é adquirir mini hábitos e aí
no meio dessa trajetória vocês vão
perceber que vai ser importante trazer é
tranquilidade pra dentro de você
nisso a meditação vai ajudar e não
precisa de uma meditação muito elaborada
vocês podem fazer agora é só prestar
atenção no seu inspirar e no seu
inspirar simplesmente perceber como que
isso acontece no seu corpo
os cientistas falam que 20 minutos são
suficientes a transformar o seu cérebro
20 minutos diários mas ainda é difícil
para você colocar 20 minutos por que não
colocar um minuto de respiração
consciente no seu dia ainda difícil uma
respiração consciente no seu dia
então vamos pegar aquela que exercício
anterior e trazer pra cá também em
alguns momentos dessa trajetória eu
sinto necessidade por incrível que
pareça eu que adoro falar de ficar em
silêncio então uma vez por por ano mais
ou menos a ficar pelo menos dez dias em
silêncio isso me ajuda a trabalhar
várias questões
e no meu último na minha última
experiência eu entendi a importância de
viver o ócio também e o ócio digo assim
é não fazer nada não fazer nada mesmo é
não ficar no videogame é não ler é não
escrever é não ficar preocupado com nada
é simplesmente deixar que o dia siga o
seu fluxo sem esperar demais dele e
deixar ele flui bom é depois disso tudo
é importante que a gente sorria então
encarar o ócio e o silêncio pode ser
sorriso pode ser difícil mas se você por
um sorriso no rosto eu garanto para
vocês que vai ser mais fácil e é muito
engraçado porque toda vez que eu penso
em sorriso lembro da minha mãe falando
pra mim filha você é mais bonita
sorrindo do que chorando gente para uma
mãe falar que você fez chorando é porque
realmente não funciona e aí eu queria um
padrão na minha cabeça que sorrir vai
ajudar eu conquistar minhas coisas e
depois os cientistas disseram que
realmente o sorriso conecta as pessoas
vocês conseguem mais coisas sorrindo
então se você não consegue sorrir não
consegue lembrar
vale colocar um alarme no celular sorria
talvez só de olhar o alarme você vai dar
risada e aí já vai valer a pena mesmo
que seja forçado sorrir porque o seu
cérebro
vai entender o movimento do seu músculo
e vai liberar um monte de hormônio que
vai ajudar o seu dia ser melhor e ele
também vai fazer com que você se conecte
com as pessoas e essa conexão como eu
disse para vocês é um diferencial nosso
de nós
homo sapiens em vivem em sociedades fez
com que a gente sobreviver se numa num
lugar selvagem como que a gente não vai
conseguir se a isso pode ajudar a gente
a sobreviver na nossa sociedade de hoje
também então faça amigos e eu não estou
dizendo só os amigos do bar
eu estou falando aqui pra vocês
encontrarem gente que joga em vocês lá
longe que faça vocês aprenderem mais
coisas que tirem vocês daquele mundinho
que vocês estão vivendo e aí nessa hora
nessa hora eu vou olhar o próximo que
não é o próximo que eu vou escolher que
esteja do meu lado também é aquela
só também que desafiadora pra mim e aí
talvez eu tenha que me conectar com ela
pensando talvez essa pessoa gosta de
animais como eu ela torça para o mesmo
time
a gente pode morar na mesma cidade a
gente deve ter alguma coisa em comum é
importante perceber que essa pessoa
também tem uma história então talvez
aquele comportamento que ela tenha tenho
porquê da loja daquela maneira
importante eu ser compreensivo com a
história daquela pessoa até porque eu
também tenho a minha história eu também
não sou perfeita muito bem e aí nessa
hora além de doar seu sorriso 2 suas
palavras escolhas suas palavras antes de
conversar com alguém
a escolha também na hora que você
precisar de alguém usar a palavra me
ajuda
se eu falar pra você me ajuda
dificilmente você vai dizer não pra mim
2 também a sua capacidade de escuta e
aquela escuta inteira aquela escuta
plena sem mexer no celular sem pensar no
que você tem pra fazer já se a situação
ainda é complicada você pode combinar
com a pessoa eu falo cinco minutos você
me escuta por cinco minutos e aí depois
a gente inverte os papéis até que a
gente entre em um acordo
bom gente nessa minha história eu vou
dizer pra vocês que eu ainda não
encontrei a iluminação mas têm tornado
os meus dias muito mais felizes é as
emoções
elas são elas por lenha na fogueira mas
usa então só emoção como combustível
para fazer com que você seja mais
compreensivo com você próprio e com o
outro e aí quem sabe no final dessa
história você consiga dialogar melhor
com os leões do seu dia
obrigada
[Aplausos]